gomorra la série phénomène est de retour
sur canal + pour une troisième saison
ultra tendues après le meurtre de nos
pieds trop les cartes sont redistribuées
tu sais on dit souvent mal à m'en plus
tôt ou tard le vice roi devient le pire
ennemi du roi on dit aussi qu aux
funérailles du roi le seul qui n'est
plus repassé son fils entre gennaro et
shiro alias l'immortel l'heure est à
l'union sacrée des six niveaux franchis
un bouquin tu vas où maintenant je dois
payer pour tout ce que j'ai fait est la
relation les simples mules tort complet
ça complique avec aussi traduire dj
ouverture d'une cheminée interdit c'est
un cliché travil euros et un peu
convaincant du tout et namur a attient
six tours à nos amours éternelles
massano dsr et une compatibilité la love
room union et produits chers et par
cause a dit que l'attaqué finish a pris
nos ports de fret
bellemare à cancun
fm oui c'est de 15,9 jane adjani day one
to protect il nous fait marrer semaine
est habitable la cannelle
j'ai perdu mon fils
qu'est ce que tu vas tu imaginer que je
vais mettre à son service à moi ton
d'oseille les pistes sud génère besoin
de gambiens profondemment solo bien aidé
à domloup toqué est en déficit les
forces impossible démenti que ces
moments douloureux et 12 secondes au
réseau d'eau lors de la coupe du noir
piste oreilles mortal si les deux hommes
sont prêts à assumer leur choix
du côté de patricia et chanel la
hiérarchie est aussi bousculé dire ce
toner gennaro castaldo réparer
immédiatement et maintenant de martha
limousine
newton analyste
et là vous avez devenir plus fortes et
comment on va devenir plus fort si on va
rester à la botte de gennaro fossé c'est
pas très bon side à aller les patriciens
forcer votre ménage de l'alliance contre
adrien maeght harrison en tout elle doit
se rapprochant de la stratégie qui vivra